hey Samuel leaves here and I want to
show you so much that just blows my mind
in property you see there's two houses
right next to each other this house
right here with the with the black door
gives a total rental income of 12,000
pounds a year but the house next door to
it which is actually cheaper house
because it's a mid terrorist rather than
terrorists the house next door brings in
thirty thousand pounds a year more than
double the rent how on earth does the
house next door bring in more than
double the rent so how it does it is
because it's used as a HMO HMO is simply
when you rent out a house rather than
renting out as a whole house to a family
you went out on a room-by-room basis now
if there's five or more rooms rented out
we call that a hate mo if there's three
or four rooms rented out like a mini HMO
we just call that a multi let property
and the reason HMOs are so popular now
in the UK is because you can literally
turn a normal house into a cash cow so
it's giving you serious money each month
and there's a few things you need to
consider when buying a haitch mo firstly
you need to be like right now we are
right in the city centre we're in
Litchfield so we are like maybe a five
minute walk from a city centre which
you've got to be if you're buying a
property the rooms will not rent out if
you're in the middle of nowhere if
you're in some field in Wales it's not
gonna work so it needs to be close to
city centre number two if you're renting
rooms out they can't be little cot rooms
because it's just it's just not legal if
it's got five bedrooms or more you're
gonna need a license so the house has to
be fit it has to be the bedrooms has to
be a minimum of 70 squared feet or six
and a half meters and you've got to have
decent sized kitchen where they gonna be
sharing the kitchen half a meter of
worktop space per tenant there's gonna
be a decent sized house don't worry
about the garden don't worry about Drive
it does need any of that stuff but
actually inside it's gonna be fit it's
going to be habitable you're gonna have
a license for the property so anything
there with five or more people you need
to get a license and I hate Shamu
licence will cost you around about
anywhere between sort of five hundred
and twelve hundred pounds
but you'll have to renew every five
years number three the house is gonna
have to be a mint-condition
now I personally like to either buy
properties that are already in mint
condition or add a lot of value and then
we finance them but if you try and rent
out a HMO a room and the houses a shabby
and the rooms are shabby and the
furniture is shabby what's gonna happen
is you're going to attract shabby
tenants a dog kennel attracts dogs so
you've got to make sure your HMO is nice
its professional so you get the best
kind of tenants number four is it's got
to be managed by somebody because hey
chairs are quite difficult to manage so
you need a letting agency in the area
that are close by and happy to manage
HMOs now you can't just find a
run-of-the-mill high-street letting
agency it needs to be someone that
specializes in hmm oh and that's what's
going to bring you your true passive
income so where would you find someone
that specializes in hmm management or
you can look on spare room code at UK
and you can see other people's HMOs and
who they're managed by and bring them in
the area or you can google it or you can
ask referrals or you can go in a high
street but just make sure if you do find
a high street letting agency they really
do have experience in HMOs ask them how
many current HMOs have got in their
books and get a real understanding if
they know what they're doing or not I've
just gone into a high street and I've
just said to them hey do you know any
letting agents in this street that deal
with HMOs and specialize in HMOs and
they've said that do so I'll go in and
ask just ask the question put all your
cards on the table so let's see what
[Music]
so I've just spoken to they do manage
HMOs but then when they saw we had a
camera they got a little bit even the
camera wasn't what happened there HMOs
and they said yeah absolutely come and
sit down and then I said do you mind if
we film and then we literally got thrown
out but they were just like no please
leave I said look I'm just only filmed
me you know what this is the stuff that
sometimes we have to go through as
camera people documenting the journey
but it's all good anyway go into later
agents ask them this is why it's
sometimes better finding HML managers on
on spare-room maybe just be hunters they
don't do HMOs but they were more
friendly than in fact the the manager
there said you've read my book and was a
big fan so that's kind of cool did you
get that video name dude let's try one
see this is it man this is what you have
to do sometimes
I've got properties in Birmingham so I
know how they work but what's the
demands do they rent out quickly or do
they take a while what's the is it so if
you put five rooms on that road would
you expect them to go out weeks or
months before they went yeah
cool thanks James take it easy mate so
just four into the estate agents Jamin
have told me that the demand is really
strong in Litchfield you're gonna get
between 400 and 450 very easily per room
which is great
and he said that the rooms went out
really really fast here so I've had to
literally go into all these different
agents in Litchfield or I actually have
my own letting agency so if I was doing
it I wouldn't need to do that but I'm
doing this to show you what you need to
do so step 5
should include things is how much you
actually gonna be putting down in the
first place now I have a rule that says
30,000 pounds per letter Ballroom is
about as high as Olga so for a four-bed
Heights MO 120 is about as high as I'll
go if it's a 5 bet I've got to 150 in
Litchfield isn't it possible maybe if
you know how to get below market value
deal which I deal with some of our other
videos you can check those out so that's
basically it make sure that the property
is in good condition when you rent it
out there's at least four little rooms
there's a hmm management company in the
area you're buying it at the right price
and lastly it's very close to the city
center like these properties are I hope
that's been helpful don't forget to stay
tuned for our next video
god bless peace out the stuff we put
ourselves through you know what bringing
this go around with me in Litchfield
with this big thing people freaked out
that when people see there's a camera
they think that you're there to like
ship them up and expose them on some
secret documentary most most people that
are successful in property they keep
their cards close to their chest they're
like you know people say how do you do
property they like keeping it close I
teach you guys everything and put myself
through this so you better freaking
subscribe man you better frickin go
around with this camera like it is not
easy trust me but I want you to see why
I was still in the real world so
subscribe right now I'll see you next
time thank you so much